Speaker 1: Hey.
So some of you might find this interesting.
I've gotten a handful of emails from from
people saying, David, I was loving those interviews
of Trumpist candidates that you were doing
over the last few months, but you haven't
done one for a while.
What's going on?
Well, it's because they keep canceling on
us.
They something is going on.
And I'll tell you what, I believe it is where
the Trump is.
Candidates, they agree to be on the show.
We schedule it.
It's an hour before the show.
And then they cancel and then they say, oh,
well, who will?
And I'll and I'll tell you what I think is
going on.
So as a reminder, we did a bunch of these
Republican candidate interviews of Republicans
endorsed by Donald Trump.
We interviewed John Gibbs.
That one was while they got almost half a
million views.
I can't imagine it was particularly good for
the John Gibbs campaign.
We did one with Darleen Swofford.
She's the one who could not or refused to
give a straight answer to the question, who
is the president of the United States?
And we did some others, and none of them really
went that well for the candidates.
But people ask for more.
And so we had more scheduled, I think four
or five different ones.
But something has happened between the time
when they agree and the time when we are ready
to do the interview.
They say, Yes, I'll do it, we get it on the
schedule.
And invariably a few minutes to an hour to
a couple of hours before the interview, they
cancel.
Sometimes it's a no call, no show, sometimes
it's, Oh, something came up.
Oh, we have a conflict.
All right, well, let's reschedule.
Yeah, we'll get back to you about rescheduling,
and then they never do.
And it's quite a list now.
Now, I'm not going to name names because.
It's it seems inappropriate to name names
and also of the list of five or so.
Some of them might really have had a conflict.
And I don't want to like pick and single out
the wrong person.
But obviously, something is going on.
Now, our colleague John, who's been scheduling
these and dealing with the schedulers, thinks
the explanation is very simple.
Oftentimes, either the candidate themselves
or if they have a publicist or a communications
person, they get excited that someone wants
to talk to them and they go, Yeah, I'll do
it.
That sounds good.
They don't research the show, and then they
go to the channel and they see John Gibbs
making a fool out of himself and half a million
views or Darlene Swap for becoming Mehmed
on Twitter with 100,000 views on a stupid
little Twitter clip that we put together because
she can't say who the president of the United
States is.
And then they say, I'm going to bail out here.
So we're available to chat.
I want to learn about their ideas.
I want to learn about the whole thing.
And I also think I should mention, like, I
kind of get it in a way, doing this show isn't
going to help them, you know, to win.
Imagine that you're running in the third district
in Michigan or whatever, right?
To win, you need to convince not just all
voters in that third district of Michigan,
because a lot of them are not going to consider
voting for a lunatic Trumpist.
You need to convince the low information voters
in the third district of Michigan.
And they're mostly not in my audience.
Right.
I mean, this is a show with a mostly progressive
audience.
Yes.
Some center right and right wingers, but most
of them don't live in the third District of
Michigan or whatever the case may be.
So I get it, like at best doing an interview
on this show.
It does nothing bad and gets you a little
bit of attention generally, but it's not the
people that ultimately are going to put you
in office.
And worst case, it gets Mehmed and it hurts
you.
So I can't say I blame them, but I wanted
to put everybody on notice with peace and
love.
Peace and love.
We're doing what we can to get more of these
people on the show.
Most of them just decline.
And even the ones that agree, I think we now
have four in a row who just bail.
They just bail.
They end up not wanting to do it.